hey guys I'm going to explain the
podcast gear that I use for both
in-person and remote interviews and the
location right now if the couch in my
living room and this couch is where a
lot of my interviews have been recorded
whether that's with micro Adam Robinson
many many others
Dave Camarillo they typically sit here
and then I sit over here and then the
gear sets were my asses right now and
I'm going to show you a bunch of that so
there are many different tools in the
toolkit this bag is a huntin bag which
is a little small for hunting and it's
probably for fishing it's a Cabela's bag
and I decided to use it as my studio in
a bag effectively for podcasting so I
will travel with this I just came back
from Austin Texas where I had this and
was doing recording with say Cheryl
Strayed and many many others so let's
take a look inside first we have extra
SD cards very important always always
always have several backup SD cards
because you will end up having a tech
issue when you least want to have a tech
issue first mic I'm going to show you is
a yellow tech mic this one is a little
quirky this is from or the model I think
is I XM and this is very cool mic
because it's all encapsulated meaning
you have the controls for recording and
so on here for playback here and it
records directly to an SD card at the
bottom so this particular mic is very
useful for any recording on the road
I've recorded intros the welcome to the
Tim Ferriss show my name is Tim Ferriss
Beauvoir at airports I've done it in
airplane bathrooms not recommended for
audio bounce but nonetheless very
versatile I use this because it also
automatically levels what you record for
many of my introductions even if I have
access to the rest of the gear that I'm
going to show you because it's so easy
to use and so fast so that's number one
and you will notice for all of these
backup batteries and backup SD card
trust me on that
you want both
and since this will oftentimes go into a
backpack separate from this bag I have
the backups in this itself next we have
the zoom so this is an h-60 I used to
use the h4n which I still sometimes use
but it is more primitive easier to mess
up and this is the basic piece of
equipment right here
so the h6 zoom is fantastic and I
upgraded it for a host of reasons number
one the recording and LCD screen is much
easier to use and next you have more
ports available for more people so the
XLR cables which I'll get to in a second
plug right in here so I can very easily
have 4 people recording to this device
and you can select which tracks you want
to use if you're recording say music or
something like that which I don't very
often do you can attach different types
of extensions like these I very very
rarely use this and that is the h6
fantastic device I almost always use
batteries as opposed to an outlet
because I never know if I'm going to
have access to an outlet so that is the
h6 now how does this actually go
together with everything else I'll show
you XLR cables alright so I travel with
many of these the only times that I've
had real issues with in-person recording
has been due to loose fittings on XLR
cables so you always want to travel with
many backups and these plug directly
into the side here so like that and then
the next piece of the puzzle so you can
see I have a lot of these the next piece
of the puzzle is the mic that you use so
there are different options some people
will use a lav mic so lavalier mic like
this and that will connect directly to
an XLR cable of some type what I found
for my guests and for purposes of
simplicity is that I like very very
simple shure sm58 stage mic these are
used by
comedians they're used by I'm sure high
school principals when they're making
announcements and auditoriums they are
very very hard to break and you want to
make sure that you get a wind cover
because you will otherwise have problems
with your peas and so on and sometimes
s's if you don't have something like
this on the mic these are relatively
cheap it probably 60 70 bucks max and
you can buy them in bulk and they simply
connect to the other end and you're in
business
you can record okay so next up we have
lots of backups okay
lots and lots and lots of mics can
imagine how much fun this is taking a
bag like this through TSA there are
constantly problems
the next mic I'm going to show you is a
little different so this is this is the
ATR 2100 this is an audio technica mic
and what makes this different is not
only does it have an XLR but it also has
a USB so I will use this when I'm
recording remotely and doing something
via telephone ie Skype
so this connects via USB to the computer
and then I'll set up this mic stand next
to the computer so it sits in just like
so and I'm off to the races a few
important points number one I use Skype
and I use ECAM call recorder and there
are many other options for recording I'm
accustomed to that works fine for me so
that is what I use other solutions allow
you to record local audio on the part of
the person who is the interviewee what I
have found because I've been interviewed
via source software before is it creates
a burden for the person on the other end
and if they are say older or less
tech-savvy it creates more problems
sometimes okay so there's a lot of tech
it's obviously developing but I use ECAM
call recorder and I use this USB mic you
want to split the recording so that you
have two different tracks to different
WAV files for both yourself and the
interviewee this is very important if
someone is a low talker and
you're a high talk or a loud talker you
need to be able to adjust those in
post-production
alright so those are some of the basics
that you will find in this first
compartment of the bag and I'll cover
just a few more things and then we can
move on number one what's on this side
well I have charging cables for iPhone
which I have all over the place I have
this what does this looks like a garbage
bag this is a poncho if you get caught
in the rain trust me you do not want
this bag getting wet with all this stuff
so this is just the poncho that fits
easily in my hand and we'll cover this
and a backpack and everything else that
I have on what are these batteries every
long interview you do use new batteries
seems wasteful but I promise you it's
better than losing half hour or an hour
of audio always have backup audio and
then we have a separate charger this is
a charger and a speaker if I want to use
it but this is a backup charger for my
iPhone which I will sometimes in a pinch
used to record with an extension which
can be a road or sure microphone that
connects directly to the Lightning port
alright so you can you can really see
that when in doubt have a backup as
Jaakko will Inc do this first public
interview on this podcast said and I've
heard from other Navy SEALs too is one
and one is none that means have a backup
if you only have one of something it's
going to break or you're going to lose
it and then case in point we have more
phone it's just in case something goes
wonky and this is going to seem odd but
trust me you want to have lots of extra
headphones seems like overkill but when
you better to better to have a not need
them to need not have and on that point
guess what I also have in all of my bags
to brush in the next toothbrush because
you will find out when you have many
different bags that you will for
whatever reason forget your goddamn
toothbrush all the time and then last I
will show you when I'm recording
via phone there are a few ways that I
keep track of notes and prep for a given
podcast if you're in person
a lot of podcasters will advise that you
should record in person because it's
better there's a certain vision Issaquah
something that you get in person that
you don't get via the phone I actually
disagree completely I think that if you
are a novice podcaster or even if you're
a very experienced many of you will get
better results recording via Skype why
because when you're recording audio only
you're able to put people more at ease
in many cases you're able to look at
notes so not only can you look at what
you've prepared but you can google
things you can look up tangents that you
want to explore you can write down
things that you want to explore later
without distracting the interviewee
very important and there are also a lot
of people even celebrities who when you
hit that record button in front of them
that red light comes on they turn into
different people either they shut down
or they go into their sound bites
they're prepared script whatever it
might be so I really enjoy recording via
Skype and there are a number of tools
that I use to make it much more
effective so one of them is Evernote I
use Evernote dozens of times a day and
have for years full disclosure I became
an adviser to the company 2009 because I
ended up using it I've used it for
research related to all of my books but
this is a sample this is a sample screen
and I'm not going to read all of it to
you but this was for a BJ Miller it was
a palliative care physician hugely
popular episode nobody really knew his
name and he has helped more than a
thousand people to die as a hospice
physician and the top I have how I was
introduced so via partner I do via Adam
gazali
who is a neuroscientist who's also been
on this podcast and below that I just
have small prompts an accidental doctor
which is something I read about him why
is he an actual doctor then Hospice org
sophomore Princeton Dinky okay so this
was a reference to his accident which he
had in college an electrocution accident
where he lost three limbs he's a triple
triple amputee so I wanted to talk about
that
photos from that time I noticed he was
always smiling so just as photos from
that time always smiling how manage
question mark alright and so on and so
forth struggle is a source of beauty no
pain no joy and then questions TF these
are just thoughts that occur to me as
I'm taking these notes so struggles and
source of beauty that's a quote from him
that I wanted to dig into then after
that so TF : how develop more empathy
more compassion which is literally
suffering together practices exercises
question mark okay so that is how I
could refer to notes looking at a screen
which is very difficult to do in person
so I am a big fan of recording remotely
but now since I've done 200 plus
episodes I feel comfortable winging it
more in person that doesn't make one
better than the other but if I want to
connect with someone then perhaps I will
try to do so in person and then have a
dinner afterwards say or lunch
beforehand which is what I do with Jocko
in lunch beforehand then podcast then
dinner together and we've since become
good friends another thing that I would
point out that is how do you punch above
your weight class in getting guests I'm
constantly asked how did you get so and
so how did you get someone so how did
you get a jamie foxx how did you get
Edward Norton well first jamie foxx took
a year and a half to schedule Edward
took a year I did those in person but I
went to them alright so number one I'm
always going to volunteer to go to them
but how it started was doing things
remotely ie this is not an in-person
interview we can do it via Skype
whenever is convenient for you
that is how you get guests that you
otherwise would be able to get you don't
ask them to come to your living room in
San Francisco
particularly if they're located in
another city or another state all right
so that's if I'm using if I'm using a
computer for notes if I am using oh no
you know pause for a second if on the
other hand you are in person and you
don't have a laptop open which I don't
like to do then I will resort to using a
notebook I don't always have a nice now
notebook like this this is for
Chris Sacca and my friends lowercase
capital I tend to get given a lot of
mole skins so here we are and show you a
few examples of how I use this because
it's I think from a formatting
perspective reasonably important so for
Kara Swisher for instance very popular
episode very well known perhaps the most
feared and respected journalist
simultaneously in tech for good reasons
so it's going to look like a mess but
here is my page for that interview those
were the prompts and I will do my
homework and I'll take notes then I will
box in a circle or a box around certain
questions that I want to make sure I
absolutely hit this may only be three to
five but I know those are going to
provoke stories and answers that I can
then use to follow up with separate
questions alright so that is for Swisher
and then afterwards or even during the
interview I will take notes there are a
couple of edits here but I wanted to
make or stops that we made for getting
water or taking a bathroom break
so I'll take edit notes also on the
paper typically I want to always have my
notes for a guest on one or two pages
why because I don't want to be flipping
back and forth and distracting things so
for John Crowley the real-life Captain
America and Bruce Banner I kid you not
this is one of my most popular episodes
in the last few months you gotta check
this guy out
so John Crowley I've known John for
years so the notes are going to be fewer
it's just one page here and then I'll
take notes
so as we adjusted volume or as I
adjusted volume because I want to
interrupt him I'm playing with the
levels on the zoom which probably just
drives my editor crazy and I edited all
my own podcasts for the first I'd say 23
you have one page alright then here we
have a page on jersey greg rick who is
the 62 year old lion of olympic
weightlifting and guys super super legit
here we have two or even
three notes two pages these are two
pages for Mahdi a condo so money a condo
or Murray condo in the US is known for
her she's very famous for think it's the
Japanese art of tidying up the magic art
of tidying up I can never remember the
title I'm sorry ma da but huge
bestseller sold millions and millions
and millions of copies this is a point
where if we were doing an interview I
would look that up on my computer but
you can only do that remotely and then I
will go through afterwards and I
highlighted things you can see here some
highlighter notes those highlighter
notes are for my intro so I always
record the intros and the bios of guests
afterwards why because I want to sit
there with them sitting facing me
reading off some long introduction and I
want to make sure I really get it right
so to get it right I want to read and to
do that I prefer to do it at home so
that I'm not distracting anyone and
these highlights are related to things
that I might put in the internal or in
the show notes that accompany the
podcast so you can see a bunch of
examples of show notes at tim vlog
forward slash podcast for every possible
episode and that is really about it and
you can see again that things i liked i
will also highlight just from my own
reference and then edit notes so a phone
call came in at 10 minutes and 15
seconds into the audio and i will send
that to my editor so I keep saying
editor editor editor what does that mean
well you are going to want somebody to
help you to clean up your audio there
are some easy tools that you can use if
you don't have much in terms of money
one would be al phonic au pho and I see
calm you upload your audio and then it
does a lot of the leveling and Hum
reduction and so on let's say there's an
air conditioner automatically like that
tech people alright Manek Li Auto magic
a little bit too much you happiness so
exciting alright let me show you
something else that may be helpful so we
talked about say the BJ Miller
preparation we didn't talk about is what
I send to editors and other people so
how do I collaborate with other people
to get stuff done well let's let's talk
about Debbie Millman so Debbie Millman
I'll pull it up and Evernote and we have
a document that looks like this and it's
pretty pretty short in this case so we
have Debbie Millman podcasts all right
and then at the top I have headlines in
all bold and all caps and these are
ideas for headlines for the podcast then
edit notes there any glitches or issues
or in the intro I mentioned author of
six books twice please remove one
mention I also flub twice remove one or
both alright so these are the things you
need to fix audio files which is then a
link to Dropbox so I upload all of my
audio files to Dropbox in a folder
that's named after the guest and then
blog posts so if there's any type of
photograph in particularly that I want
to use or any type of bio that I want to
use and then I will drop it in here
sometimes I type it out other times I
will record the intro and then we'll see
here under blog post says please base
text off of the podcast intro audio but
add editorial and creative director
print magazine end quotes somewhere
names I mentioned in the intro that you
might need spelling for Massimo Vignelli
Milton Glaser Stephen Heller etc and
then see Dropbox for social handles so
I'll ask guests in advance to supply
photos they own that we can use that
they are very important and then also
preferred biosocial handles and so on
and this document so this is an Evernote
this is an Evernote doc that I can share
I'll take that Evernote link and I'll
drop it into slack so in slack there is
at inter show channel and I'll say at
whoever I'm trying to get the attention
of new all-caps podcast ready for
editing guest name
Lync thank you for confirming receipt
then it's off my plane at that point it
goes out and unless there's something
like here for instance it says note I
need to see the blog post and approved
before it goes live but otherwise I am
done with the podcast it gets slated
there's a Google Doc where we have the
schedule it gets slated and I don't
longer have to worry about it everything
else is handled so that in a huge
nutshell is how I record prep and even
move podcasts into post-production so
hope you guys find that helpful this is
very very simple so literally with stuff
in this bag and this and this that's all
I've needed to get to 150 million
downloads and Counting
and I've no plans on making it more
sophisticated because as Morgan Spurlock
famed documentary filmmaker and
nonfiction TV producer and host has said
once you get fancy fancy gets broken so
don't get too fancy hope that's helpful
hope you enjoyed the video if you would
like to see my favorite piece of content
that I put out every week it is a short
newsletter five bullet Friday it's free
five bullet points with the coolest
things that I have been finding using
testing in a given week I put it out
every Friday you can digest it in about
five minutes take a look
Bible of writing